When Humans Started Shaving Different Parts
of Our Bodies
Both sexes have a love-hate relationship with
removing body hair.
We’ve been pulling, plucking, burning, tweezing
and ripping out undesirable hair since the
dawn of time.
It’s believed that as far back as 4,000
B.C., women were using dangerous substances
like arsenic and quicklime to get the job
done.
Meanwhile, the Egyptians, who never did anything
halfway, removed all of their body hair from
head to toe.
They really liked the sleek look, but it also
had a practical purpose.
Being hairless discouraged the spread of disease
and vermin such as lice and other icky creepy-crawlies.
By 500 B.C., Roman ladies had learned how
to use pumice stones and even a primitive
version of the razor.
Let’s fast-forward to more recent times.
When did our modern-day obsession with silky-smooth
armpits and legs first take hold?
As far as armpits are concerned, we can pinpoint
it almost to the day.
In May of 1915, the upscale magazine Harper’s
Bazaar ran an ad featuring a young model in
a sleeveless, slip-like dress posing with
both arms over her head.
You may be thinking, “So what?”
Well, up until that time, fashion – and
propriety – dictated that women were covered
to the wrist and to the ankle.
A dress that exposed the underarms was nothing
short of revolutionary.
In fact, just the utterance of the word “underarm”
out loud was enough to call for the smelling
salts mere weeks earlier.
Now, it was becoming perfectly acceptable.
It also meant since underarms were body parts
that had always been covered, whether or not
they needed shaving had been a moot point
and little discussed.
If it didn’t show, why bother?
And yet, here was an ad cajoling women that
it was necessary to remove “objectionable”
hair.
To think just days earlier women had no idea
such a problem even existed!
There were several marketing strategies employed
to lure women into jumping on the shaving
bandwagon, most of which appealed to the timeless
desire to be trendy.
The obsession worked its way down to the middle
class slowly but surely, as sleeveless and
sheer dresses became popular among that demographic.
Women’s razors and depilatories were finally
being offered for sale in the Sears Roebuck
catalog in 1922.
This was the same year they started to sell
– you guessed it – sleeveless and sheer
dresses.
By this point, advertisers didn’t feel the
need to justify their product’s purpose
anymore, and could instead start spending
their budgets differentiating their product
from their competitors.
This meant that women had been won over – or
brainwashed as some might say – and it was
no longer a question of convincing them if
they should shave their underarms in advertisements;
now it came down to convincing them that a
particular product was the best choice to
remove the hair that women didn’t realize
until recently was objectionable in the first
place.
The leg shaving phenomenon was a lot slower
to catch on.
It’s true that during the 1920s the flappers
brought with them a decade of much shorter
dresses coming into vogue, but by the 1930s
hemlines became much longer again.
There were some fashion and beauty writers
loudly proclaiming that leg hair was on a
par with leprosy, boldly referring to it as
a “curse”.
Regardless, it seemed that the majority of
women were content to leave well enough alone
and not worry about shaving their legs.
The fashion mavens just couldn’t stir up
the same frenzy this time around as they had
with armpit hair.
It seems that most women were a tad more hesitant
when it came to shaving and therefore drawing
attention to their legs, as opposed to their
underarms.
After all, the leg’s closest neighbors are
the “private” bits.
You wouldn’t want anyone to think you were
that kind of girl, or give men any kind of
wrong impression.
Then World War II erupted, and that iconic
pin-up picture of Betty Grable became part
of popular culture almost overnight.
It’s only a slight exaggeration to say that
the women of America have been shaving their
legs ever since.
Why, you ask?
Because Betty’s legs looked amazing, and
to emulate that look, you had to wear a short
skirt and sheer stockings.
You also had to shave your legs, as nothing
killed the effect you were trying to create
more than leg hair poking through your silky
stockings.
Now, what about the guys?
It’s impossible to know who the first men
to shave their beards were.
It’s pretty certain the story begins during
the Stone Age, where cave paintings show Neanderthal
man using seashells as tweezers to pluck out
unwanted hairs.
Flint blades, believed to be the first razors
used for shaving, have been dated back as
far as 30,000 B.C. Flint would provide a very
sharp edge, but would also become dull very
quickly.
Therefore, it’s probably safe to say that
flint was man’s first disposable razor.
There is evidence that in ancient times Egyptian
men shaved their beards for religious as well
as aesthetic purposes.
For the most part, it’s the Egyptians who
are given credit for introducing shaving as
part of a daily hygienic routine.
Shaving was very important to Egyptian men,
as facial hair was indicative of personal
neglect- so much so that affluent people typically
kept a barber as a member of their household
staff.
Alexander the Great is thought by some to
have introduced the practice of shaving to
the Greeks around 300 B.C.
Even if his role there is overstated, he definitely
was a huge proponent of it and helped popularize
shaving among the Greeks.
It is thought he took up the practice of shaving
his beard as a beard gives the enemy something
to grab onto during battle, putting soldiers
with beards at a distinct disadvantage.
Not surprisingly, cropped hair and closely
shaven skin became all the rage in Greece
at the time.
There was soon a definite divide between the
shaven and the unshaven – at least as far
as the shaven were concerned anyway.
In fact, some etymologists think that the
term “barbarian” actually comes from “barba”,
meaning “beard”.
Hence, barbarians were simply all those who
were “unbarbered” or didn’t shave.
(An alternate theory is that “barbarian”
comes from the Proto-Indo-Eurpoean root *barbar,
meaning something to the effect of “stammering”
or “unintelligible”, referring to the
people’s language, rather than lack of shaving.)
Whatever the case, it’s plain to see that
our relationship with the removal of unwanted
body hair is a long and colorful one.
Once mankind was gifted with the invention
of toilet paper to ball up and staunch the
bleeding from the inevitable shaving-induced
nicks and cuts, we could realize just how
difficult the landscape our ancestors had
to traverse really was.